let me ask you a question if you
say
you think the word
of
steelworker
what words come to your mind if you say
steelworkers what is wrong with
demanding for
an easy
safe
kind of
their
income
a path to a
safe place for them to win or excuse me
to work
yesterday's appearance by pennsylvania
democratic senate candidate john
fetterman
has a lot of people wondering if he's
physically up for this job of senator
now it's something his republican
challenger has increasingly begun asking
on the trail and joining me now is dr
mathemats republican candidate for u.s
senate in pennsylvania now dr oz your
team has uh
has come under fire for pointing out
legitimate questions about fetterman's
stamina and and mental acuity at this
point
um and isn't isn't that a fair question
to ask given what's at stake for not
just the people of pennsylvania but for
the whole country with this one senate
race
well as a physician i feel badly that
he's struggling that stated for
democracy to work laura you have to be
able to answer questions from the press
from voters you've got to hear what what
folks your constituents are going to say
and he's just not been out there and the
question we're asking is a legitimate
one are you hiding because you don't
want to talk about your radical views or
is it because your health is such a
problem and if it's the stroke that you
had that's causing issues come talk to
us let's figure out some way we can have
a debate it's the best way for us to
identify how we're different from each
other and let the public decide who they
want to vote for but if it's your
radical views you're hiding from i'm not
i won't let you get away with that i
mean you have the most radical position
john fetterman of any candidate for
senate in a contested race in this
country and it's my obligation my duty
to make sure voters in pennsylvania
appreciate that well this reminds me of
the biden campaign
in 2020 does it not i mean
he was essentially a hologram candidate
they only trotted him out rarely they
kind of cited covid
campaigned in the basement had a few
debates but it was
it was kid gloves treatment of biden to
protect him to get trump and you you see
some of the same dynamics at play here
and they're seizing on every
you know any you know just
idiotic points about what something you
said about crudite now that's the most
important thing in pennsylvania as
they're against fracking and claiming
that they're for the steel workers
and for the oil
for the oil guys
without question let me just walk you
through one example because there's a
very hot topic in pennsylvania john
federman has argued we should release
one-third of all prisoners in
pennsylvania he's bragged about all the
murderers that he has pardoned yet
philadelphia has got the highest murder
rate ever
and that's up 60 since he's been in
office in addition he wants to legalize
all drugs including create these heroin
injection sites we've got the largest
open-air drug market in kensington in
philadelphia in the country and then he
wants sanctuary cities with an open
border and he's doesn't understand that
brings fentanyl into our communities and
pennsylvania's been hit harshly top five
in the country and fentanyl deaths
that's why when the fraternal order of
police endorsed me recently it was
unanimous they were so angry at
fetterman here's the catch laura the
coast california and new york they are
pouring money into big time they just
want to get the 51st seat they don't
understand how dangerous he is how
radical he is and i argue guys come help
dr oz.com is my site come support me
make sure we can arm up and defend
ourselves and also define who john
fetterman is i'm putting a lot of
resources in this campaign we will win
we dramatically close the polls as you
know but in order to compete you've got
to be able to explain to everybody
exactly who john federman is because
he's fighting at home as you point out
but he but dr oz he is the ultimate
phony populist they obviously are
worried about a more populist a
republican party because they're all
trying to pretend to be popular populist
tim ryan in ohio is doing the exact same
thing mark kelly tries to play it jon
tester in montana and now this is just
the most recent iteration of that but
they're destroying the oil and gas
industry as they claim to be for the the
regular people and the same thing with
the steel industry is they want to ship
our jobs overseas so this phony populism
of fetterman with the hoodie
that has to be completely exploded and
exposed for what it is to me that's the
that's the winning way to win this
election
it's frustrating because he's called
fracking a stain on pennsylvania called
for a moratorium on it he wants to
regulate it to death and yeah and then
he points to his own hometown he says
and i was in braddock it's a small
little town you know two thousand people
it's much smaller since he became his
part-time mayor violent crime quadrupled
under his watch and then a year after
leaving the crime dropped 60 percent
there's a reason that john federman has
never actually had a real job well has
he i don't think he can do a real job
yeah well speaking of a real job has he
agreed to a real debate
any debates
no
no i've accepted from five major media
companies five debates he's not
responded he will not accept i just need
him to come out and play he owes it to
america he owes it to pennsylvania
to make sure that we can understand
where he stands on these issues he is
far more radical than he acknowledges
all right that's how you become a
hologram as you point out he won't he
won't agree to debate dr oz thank you
why is he hiding hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else